thank you very much melinda crane is
awesome minister
hello minister peter and ladies and
gentlemen
well speaking about as you said
the future of industry just look north
for example to sweden
they're 160 kilometers below the arctic
circle one can visit a pioneer
of greening our economy in the town of
lulea
a steel plant just started using
hydrogen gas
to reduce iron ore
and some days ago another producer in
the same region
announced that he will build a large
scale green hydrogen plant as part of a
new steel production facility
these are not isolated cases we all know
that today
the steel industry is responsible for up
to nine
percent of global emissions nine percent
and thus companies in northern sweden
have to and want to bring down their
carbon footprint to zero
with water vapor the only byproduct
their way to achieve this is clean
hydrogen hydrogen derived from renewable
energy
such as hydroelectric power
a source that is as abundant in
scandinavia
as high quality iron ore
and these swedish entrepreneurs match
exactly the spirit of our european green
deal
we want to reconcile the way we produce
and do business
with the health of our planet it's time
to do this
because what is good for the planet is
good for business and good for us all
the energy transition it is at the heart
of our european green deal and this is
why
i am delighted to be able to talk to you
today at the berlin
energy transition dialogue sadly because
of the pandemic
only virtually
let me be clear the european green deal
is as important today as it has been
before
covet 19. if anything
it has become even more important
there is increasing evidence that the
loss of biodiversity
is one of the root causes for this
global pandemic
and while much of the world's activity
froze during lockdowns and shutdowns
our planet continued to get hotter
and we see it all around us from the
collapse
of the glacier northern india which just
recently killed dozens of people
to the many many crops destroyed in many
european countries by the severe
droughts of the last years
climate change is the massive
crisis beyond covet 19.
and therefore after the pandemic there
can
be no backsliding no return
to economic activity based on fossil
fuels
at the expense of climate and nature
a bit more than a year ago europe has
said indeed
that it wants to become the first
climate neutral continent by 2050
and last december eu leaders agreed to a
greenhouse gas emission reduction target
of at least minus 55
by 2030. the first
ever european climate law will hopefully
soon come into force
and all of this is part of our
commitment
to deliver on the paris agreement
and this is something that the business
community has
asked us to do for many years clear
transparent and firm targets
so that companies have the certainty
that they need
to plan ahead for the future to turn
their investments into
green investments because in our fight
against climate change
business is our close and indispensable
partner
our european green deal is
our strategy for sustainable growth
and now it is also our roadmap out of
the crisis
one third one third of the investments
from our recovery plan next generation
eu
will finance the goals set out in the
european green deal
and together with the eu budget we are
investing
1.8 trillion euro
1.8 trillion so this will bring
massive investments to build forward
better
and more sustainable
next generation eu is an opportunity to
boost
our energy transition and let me give
you two examples
the first one with next generation eu
we want to start a european renovation
wave the main objective is
to make our buildings more energy
efficient
buildings notably account today for
40 of our emissions 40
so by refurbishing and refitting them we
can improve their energy performance
we cut emissions and at the same time
we reduce our energy bills and in
addition
our renovation wave brings a much needed
boost
to our construction sector and new jobs
to our communities
second with next generation eu
we will invest in clean hydrogen as
never before clean hydrogen is a perfect
means
towards our goal of climate neutrality i
just gave you the
examples from northern sweden but also
in germany and other countries
numerous regions can benefit from
hydrogen
just think of the so-called ruager beet
clean hydrogen can power heavy
industries
propel our cars or trucks and planes
store seasonal energy and heat up our
homes
and all of this with almost
zero emissions
for the steel industry hydrogen is
the opportunity on their way to more
sustainability
steel is everywhere we know it in cars
ships bridges buildings
washing machines you name it we need
steel but we want it to be sustainable
and clean hydrogen is the way to go
and to help with this transition last
year
we came up with a road map towards a
hydrogen
ecosystem in europe
like with our european green deal we set
clear targets
we want to have an annual production
capacity
for renewable hydrogen of 1 million
tons by 2024 and
10 million tons by 2030
and by 2050 we want renewable hydrogen
technologies to be deployed at
large scale to reach all hard
to decarbonize sectors in our economy
these are ambitious goals but they are
realistic too
to get there we have to start now
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions by at
least 55
towards the end of the decade we have to
act
today because 2030 is just around the
corner
and this is why by this summer
we will revise our entire climate and
energy legislation
to make it fit for 55
and let me give you a short preview
of what we will be proposing
first we will enhance the eu
emission trading system we will
extend it to the maritime sector
and we will better apply it to aviation
we are also looking into introducing
emission trading
for buildings and for road transport
carbon must have its price
because nature cannot pay the price
anymore
second we will come forward with
proposals
to boost renewable energy and improve
energy efficiency
for example we will propose measures to
increase
the the energy efficiency of appliances
from vacuum cleaners to smartphones you
name it
we will also invest in electric charging
infrastructure and battery technology
to help the car industry on its way
towards electricity
that's the future clearly
this is also what consumers want the
sales of electric cars
doubled last year reaching almost 10
percent of car sales in europe
and there's more to come finally
we want to take green financing
to the next level because to achieve our
2030 goal
we need to boost green investment
we know that we will have to invest
around
3 350 billion euros more
per year in the energy system in the
coming decade to make it sustainable
our european union green bond standard
for example and the eu taxonomy
will lead the way it will bring
much needed clarity on what accounts for
sustainable
eco-friendly activities
because we know how important this is
for investors
who are looking for truly sustainable
projects
they don't want green washing they want
truly sustainable projects
again our targets are ambitious but we
can reach them
and we need others to match our ambition
and they do from south korea to japan
from south africa to china
of course we want to make sure that they
live
up to their commitments so not only on
paper
but on the ground and we stand ready to
help our partners on their way forward
and i must say we're really excited that
president biden
rejoined the paris agreement on his very
first day in office
i also commend joe biden for his plan to
convene a leaders summit
for earth day because now
is the time for action
europe is world leader when it comes to
innovation of clean technologies
we stand ready for global leadership on
climate change
with our partners a shared commitment
to a net zero emissions pathway by 2050
would make climate neutrality a new
global benchmark
and that would be a powerful message in
the run-up
to the cop 26 the next u n climate
change conference
and finally we also need
a paris-style agreement for biodiversity
let us be very clear that for example
when we lose
forests we don't just
lose green space or natural habitat
we lose a key ally in our fight against
climate change
and this is why the european union will
soon present a legal framework
for the restoration of healthy
ecosystems
it is why we will protect at least 30
percent
of land and sea in the european union
and we are ready to broker the same
ambition at global level
at the next u.n biodiversity summit in
kunming
because this will have to be like cop21
was for climate
the path to carbon neutrality offers
great opportunities for innovation
growth
and sustainable jobs european companies
know this
they bet on the opportunities offered by
clean technologies
at an early stage and their pioneering
spirit is now paying off
but let us make no mistake if we want
our companies
to continue on their way to zero
emissions we
must insist on fairness and the level
playing field for them
let me for last time
return to the example of steel one of
the most
traded commodities internationally
we want european companies to heavily
invest in expensive technologies
to make steel green
green steel costs around 100 euro
more per ton than traditionally
carbon heavy produced steel so clearly
we have to prevent cheap products from
abroad
from undermining our efforts
and this is why this year we will
present
a carbon border adjustment mechanism
with this mechanism
we will impose a co2 charge on certain
products entering the european union
we work so hard to reduce our emissions
thus we can't accept to import at the
same time emissions from abroad
and the carbon board adjustment
mechanism should motivate
foreign producers but also eu importers
to also reduce their carbon emissions
this would be our preferred solution
ladies and gentlemen from hydrogen
valleys to climate friendly
buildings from green steel to zero
emission cars
our european green deal will affect
almost
all aspects of our daily lives
it will make our lives better
because as we've seen our european green
deal
involves much more than cutting
emissions
it is about making systemic
modernization
across our economy society
and industry it is about building a
better world to live in
so let's work on this together
you can count on me and i know that i
can count on you
and thank you very much for the
attention
[Music]
you